The Supreme Court
is about to decide
do you have to pay union dues
if your workplace is unionized?
When I worked at
CBS and ABC,
I had to.
I was told,
this is a union shop.
You must pay up.
But now the court may say for government workers,
that's unconstitutional.
So unions are nervous.
If we lose this case,
the entire public sector will be right to work.
Right to work would mean
unions could no longer
force workers to join
and pay dues.
The union's values are all money.
Teacher Rebecca Friedreichs
filed a lawsuit that
went to the Supreme Court
because she says,
unions
are bullies.
If someone
takes something from me.
You understand why she says that
when you
listen to some union leaders speak.
And I'm going to punch you in the face
and push you in the dirt.
That guy is boss
of the biggest teachers union.
And you sick people.
Rebecca got mad at her union
during the last recession
when she tried to save some teachers jobs
by getting all the teachers
to take a slight pay cut.
They were willing to take a cut?
Absolutely.
We're willing to have that discussion
and all of America was taking a pay cut pretty much.
Why should we be any different?
But the union wouldn't even allow her to survey
the other teachers.
They said absolutely not.
Would not let me send out that survey.
Then, angering her further:
They told me,
"Rebecca, don't worry about those teachers
who are going to lose their jobs.
The union's going to take care of them.
We're going to give them
a seminar
on how to get unemployment benefits."
So Rebecca decided
she no longer wanted to pay union dues.
She sued the California Teachers Association
and after three years,
the Supreme Court heard her case.
This is so exciting.
Our voices were heard today.
Union voices were heard too.
They protested on the steps outside the court.
We fight for equality.
They were worried
because Supreme Court watchers said
Rebecca was likely to win.
The case that has the potential
to decimate
the way that public sector unions function.
But then,
Supreme Court Justice Antonin Scalia has died.
That was the most devastating day.
Without Scalia's vote, the court deadlocked.
That meant unions could continue
forcing teachers to pay dues.
It is a huge win for public sector unions.
But now a new case
filed by this government worker
Mark Janus
is about to be heard by the court.
With Neil Gorsuch,
the ninth justice,
unions are so worried
they even agreed to speak to me.
Our members want their union.
They want their union
to have power.
Steve Kreisberg represents the union
that's being sued
by Mark Janus.
It's his right
to dissent
and not be a member of our union.
He only has to pay the fees
that are used to represent him.
What's the point in that
if you have to pay?
That's the main reason
he doesn't want to join.
He doesn't want to be forced to pay for something
he doesn't agree with.
Well, I'm not sure
if he doesn't agree with it
or if he just simply doesn't want to pay
because he'd like to get those
services for free.
The union could say,
"We're bargaining
for all you teachers.
If you don't
join the union,
you're a free rider."
I never asked for their representation.
All right, but you're getting it
and presumably benefitting.
If I saw their
representation as a benefit,
then I could agree with that.
But I don't see it as a benefit.
Their benefits
aren't worth
the moral costs.
To me,
that sounds like the words
of a right-wing activist,
not the words of a teacher.
She was a teacher
who got together with other teachers
and said
let's take a pay cut
so nobody has to get fired,
and the union said "No,
you may not even put that to a vote."
They elected somebody else.
So she has no more right
to call a vote
than Hillary Clinton has the right
to conduct foreign policy
for the United States of America.
Thomas Jefferson believed that
to compel a man to contribute
to propagation of opinions
to which he disbelieves
is sinful
and tyrannical.
Thomas Jefferson
had no sense
of 21st century labor relations.
It is mine!
No, he probably didn't.
You do not take what is mine!
Now the Supreme Court
will decide.
Oral arguments
are scheduled for Monday.
The court will announce its decision
sometime this summer.
I hope they'll see it
the way Jefferson did.
Forcing someone
to pay for something they don't want
is tyranny.